rodrigo chávez ya es presidente electo y
va a ocupar el palacio presidencial de
costa rica- cuáles son las principales
fortalezas de chávez podemos hablar como
ya lo estaba mencionando alejandro un
poco de su imagen que busca romper con
el llamado establishment así es digamos
que la presencia de un outsider en el
palacio de gobierno en san josé pues de
alguna forma refleja un cambio en la
política costarricense recordemos que
costa rica siempre ha estado digamos
dominado por dos partidos principales el
partido liberacionista y el partido
socialcristiano en ese sentido es un
nuevo aire en la política pero refleja
también la insatisfacción de los
costarricenses frente a la democracia
allí asoman más más los riesgos que los
beneficios en primer lugar porque chávez
no cuenta con la mayoría en el
parlamento tendría que hacer muchos
esfuerzos para lograr eso digamos esas
negociaciones y concitar al final de
cuentas una coalición que le permita
gobernar y en segunda medida siempre
chávez desde la campaña electoral
siempre propuso generar una serie de
cambios en las instituciones
democráticas siempre atacó el poder
judicial atacó las instituciones y eso
no es un buen mensaje para una
democracia modelo en américa latina como
es la costarricense entonces creo yo que
asuma mucho más los riesgos que los
beneficios de que haya llegado chávez al
palacio nacionalizándose